hello everyone we're going to be
starting here in just a minute
and in the meantime thank you for your
patience
foreign
all right welcome everyone to today's
session today we're going to be doing
our
session one of our logic data
this is the program that is hosted by
the louisiana biomedical research
network and so today we will have an
overview of the program
but we will also start going into some
practical aspects of how to load data in
different
formats txt csv
how to summarize that data we'll try
both in r
and in python but before we begin i want
to give a brief
overview of what this program is going
to be all about kind of walk you through
where we headed
with this program and what are you
expected to
learn as a result of participating in
this program
so again today is our first session
and we're going to be
we're going to be speaking about
different aspects of data science in
application to
biological or biomedical data as those
will be the examples that we will use
i will be one of the speakers but
together with me we have clinton kuna
which will be doing part of the session
hello clinton um but also we will rely
on some materials
that were prepared by our team and you
will be able to interact with them as
well
getting help with all kinds of different
uh technical issues that you might come
across
so what is omixlogic all about omixlogic
is all about
applying data science principles to
different biomedical domains
using omix data and that includes
oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture and so we
call this program
data science for biomedical discovery
or biology as a data science is kind of
like the overall
term for what we do and what our company
provides is we provide
different tools and methods for big data
analysis that includes
processing analysis and integration of
omics data like genomics and
transcriptomics phenotypic data like
images clinical data and also we
discussed this in the context of very
specific project
examples we also provide a network of
mentors and these mentors come from
different universities
including louisiana state university
georgetown university and
others and our mentors are typically
experts
in different domains so they come and
they share their perspective on a
particular project example
and we have a number of programs that
are designed around that
one-on-one or small group mentoring
we also provide access to training
materials so today we will take a look
at some of those materials to get you
started with
data science but when i mentioned data
science what does that actually mean
so data science is the convergence of
methods to deal with data store
organize manipulate ways to
analyze that data or statistical
analysis
and ways to apply that to a particular
domain
so data science typically when we hear
data science we think of it
applied to many different domains
clinical business internet of things
finance and marketing
well this specific program is going to
be focused on the application to the
biological domain
and so we will use research examples
that illustrate
how omics data could be useful in
addressing some of the challenges in
precision medicine
and different aspects of biological
research so the program itself
will cover some introductory material on
statistical analysis and machine
learning
we will discuss how that plays a role in
experimental design
so how do we analyze data to spot real
signal and differentiate from technical
variation
we will talk about data mining and what
it means to mine data for
patterns and finding associations that
might be meaningful
and how to also test those associations
and then we will talk about
the complexity of biological systems and
how that
applies to the different types of data
that are available and we will use as
examples in this program
in the context we will also try
different types of tools these will be
big data processing tools using our
t-bind for platform
but also scripting in python and r and
so what we hope
is that as a result of this particular
program
you will cover the following topics so
introduction to data science and
bioinformatics how the two are related
but also what are the specific
aspects of data science that typically
are not so
covered as well in bioinformatics itself
we'll talk about data processing
cleaning and exploration
the applications of data science and
biomedicine we'll use several examples
for that
we will talk about different types of
machine learning algorithms and we will
apply them to next generation sequencing
data
we'll talk about the challenge of
integrating various signals from
x omics or multi-omics data sets and
then we will also talk about the subject
of deep learning
and how that could be applied to omix
but also to clinical phenotypes
so as a result what we hope to do is
connect the research question or the
real need that exists out there
with different aspects of data analysis
that has
an impact on how we think about the data
or the experimentation that
generates that data how do we explore
that data and discover patterns that
turn into hypotheses
how can we test those hypotheses and
what that can reveal about
different types of biological
experiments producing high throughput
data
that oftentimes does not necessarily
fit our knowledge and so how this
data-driven
approach to data analysis is critical
for discovery and how data science plays
a major role
in that process so let me give you
an example of why data science is such
an important part and how does it apply
to such
intuitive applications like precision
medicine so
as we all know precision medicine is the
future of medicine in the sense that we
are relying more and more on complex
data generated
for clinicians to make decisions and
these decisions could be about treatment
it could be about outcomes it could be
risk stratification
and so in that process we are also
talking about data becoming more and
more precise
or also complex and so when we think of
traditional medicine
which is medicine based on symptoms
those are at the top of the iceberg or
the clinical data that we can see and
observe
the manifestation of disease and
symptoms that are
clearly identifiable and we want to
connect them with the underlying
molecular drivers of that process to
be able to intervene so to be able to
spot specific patterns
that can reveal some actionable insights
that is one example another example
where
machine learning and data science are
very applicable
is drug discovery and drug repurposing
where
the length of time from
ideas about what might work to actually
getting a drug on the market
is not only expensive but also very long
and that's where
data science and the application of
machine learning will play a major role
so we'll talk about some examples in
that
but also in clinical trials how going
from
recruiting patients for clinical trials
with
a broad kind of high level
symptom-based recruitment is also
changing because now they're being
recruited with
biomarker and that makes those very
precise and that makes that also very
different
from the traditional kind of landscape
of patients
and disease stratification so we will
also talk in this
program about different types of
vomiting data so as you probably know
omix data
could be classified into several
different types for example phenomics
talks about phenotypic data
genomics talks about dna variation trend
epigenomics talks about epigenetic
regulation and different signals that we
can capture about chromatin
structures and accessibility of dna we
can also talk about the result of that
regulation which results in
expression of mrna and other types of
rnas that could be collectively called
transcriptomics and so when we talk
about biomedical omics data
we talk about different examples with
diagnostics for cancer biology
basic biology where we try to understand
single cell and tissue composition
or even looking at the impact of
different variations at the microbiome
and for example immunity to infection
now what characterizes
all of these examples is the
availability of unstructured data so
many times we rely on data that has been
generated by processes which we can call
high throughput
and what that means is that they are
automated and because of that automation
a lot of the data is generated in
unstructured formats which
for example could mean the collection of
short reads
that contain sequences abundances and
the
process of taking that unstructured data
and turning it into something useful is
what we call
processing so for example we can process
whole exome sequencing and whole genome
sequencing to identify the actual
mapped reads to a reference genome and
then we can ask the question well
where are the changes that are
significant we can talk about dna
methylation
and chip sequencing where we take a look
at
immunoprecipitation and methylation
processes that
help us extract meaningful insights
about epigenomic regulation or
epigenetic regulation sorry
we can look at rna sequencing or levels
of gene expression
and we can also look at peak calling for
example for proteomics and metabolomics
trying to understand
what kinds of proteins and metabolites
are being
expressed in the sample so taking that
raw data
from images or reads and turning it
into structured data is basically
converting that raw data into
a table and once that table is there
we need to understand the different
aspects
of that data which might include numeric
data
continuous but also categorical where we
have
names of samples groups of samples names
of genes or proteins
or whatever else it might be and so in
the context of data science for
biomedical discovery
we will talk about how we can do data
processing
how we can explore that data and how we
can perform data analysis
relying on what we understood about the
data sets that we have
for some kind of inference so for
interpretation really how can we take
what we have found in a given sample
and generalize it about the general
population disease
patient etc so let's take a look at an
example
first of all genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics
and epigenomics all of these types of
data sets
are complex they involve many different
features
like genes metabolites proteins and
typically
as a data scientist our challenge is to
convert it into something that is
insightful so that might mean
some kind of transformation or some kind
of
organization of data plus some visual
tools
to help make that interaction with data
intuitive for people that
don't necessarily go through the process
of making those steps
but actually can take a look and it's
clear
what is the message what is the status
and so we'll learn in this program how
to perform
these steps the transformation steps
how we can visualize appropriate types
of data with appropriate types of
visualization
and how we can use advanced techniques
like principal component analysis or
hierarchical
clustering like in these examples so
that we can extract some meaningful
information and share it with others
we will also take a look at the
relationship
between what the data means and how it
applies to the biological context like
taxonomy
and how we can use our understanding of
the data properties to again communicate
the differences in our data in our
biological samples
with some clear visual messages
so to talk about that we need to
understand that
data comes from many different sources
and whatever that source is when we
make it into a structured data set we
have to typically go through a
series of steps so that we can prepare
that data for analysis and so that will
be
the first part of our program we will
talk about several different examples of
working with data sets like that then
for
us to work with a computer we need to
convert
the full table or whatever structure
data we have
into specific objects these could be
vectors
matrices arrays or data frames and so
we'll talk about how these different
types of objects are useful for storing
and operations with the data
so that we can extract some associations
to correlations visual information etc
we will also talk about how
visualization of this data
is also guided by different types of
data properties so we'll talk about
what is categorical data what is
continuous data how do we combine
them together to summarize data for
example if we have
metadata about different objects in our
table
how do we create what's called crosstabs
or summary tables
that essentially give us a summary of
what is in the data
we'll then talk about some useful
statistical
measurements or properties of data that
allow us to spot
major patterns right away so you might
think of it
as box plots for again for example that
summarize some elements of distribution
mean
an interquartile range so that we can
clearly see
major patterns in large data sets and
we'll also talk about scatter plots and
different ways to
prepare data for scatter plots that are
informative so that we can spot
relationships between elements in our
data
now importantly because we're talking
about the biomedical domain
we also will have to touch on data
normalization
and understanding of how the data was
prepared so
a lot of the properties in the data
might not fit the assumptions
of the methods for exploratory and
in-depth analysis and so we'll talk
about
steps to normalize and change
properties of data without really
changing the data
itself so that we can test things like
technical replicates or biological
replicates and how
useful are they in being used for
downstream analysis
then finally we'll talk about
exploratory data analysis
and what that really means how do we use
elements of machine learning and
statistical testing
to be able to understand how the
patterns characterize the data set
in general and what does that mean for
downstream
statistical or comparative analysis
when we talk about statistical analysis
we'll talk about
how the analysis itself of a subset of
data
is intended to really tell us something
about the greater population
and how different elements of the
statistical analysis like p
values false discovery rate
and other log fault change and other
measurements
can help us find a statistically
significant signal
that could be used for predictive
analysis or
for inference how can we use those
different statistical measurements to
really give us reliable results
we'll also then talk about data mining
and classification so we'll talk about
different methods for data mining like
principal component analysis and
different types of clustering
and how to then also rely on different
elements of classification like decision
trees
or random forests to analyze and
classify our data but also to do feature
selection
so finally we will touch a little bit on
different algorithms behind some of
these methods so that we understand
what goes into the different steps
of an algorithm that can help us
understand and extract meaningful
features
inside a data set and how we can use the
different parameters
included in that algorithm so that we
can optimize it for the type of an
objective that we have like feature
selection using
stepwise linear discriminant analysis as
displayed here in this slide
finally we will touch on elements of
deep learning
and so as exciting as it is there are
also many different challenges
with deep learning that are specific to
different types of data
different types of network architecture
and different types of applications
where they have been
demonstrated to work better than for
example classical machine learning
and where they are performing in such a
way that they're addressing
other challenges that are not related
with
for example the optimization and the
accuracy
but are related to the type of data and
the challenge with really preparing data
for analysis and for training
now all of these are some of the
conceptual topics that we will cover
but we will also go in to some practical
coding sessions and in those coding
sessions we will take
a look at how to implement some of the
analysis that we described
and you find useful pieces of code
that you can save for your own personal
repository of
coding libraries that you will rely on
to work
on an independent project and so we hope
that after
this program many of you will be able to
benefit from some of these coding
exercises
and actually take it further and apply
them to a data set of your own
so here are some coding challenges that
we will
go through including some of them today
we will learn how to load data from
different formats we will learn about
summarizing
preparing them with different types of
transformation techniques
how to perform statistical analysis and
also how to perform different types of
visualizations and how they are useful
for different kinds of questions as i
mentioned this will also include
r and r studio as well as python and
some development environment like visual
code studio
so we will talk about how we go from
just
exercises to then working in an
environment that you can set up
how to load libraries how to organize
your workspace
how to save different files in such a
way that you can find them
and then also how to run your analysis
and save results
that you can use or maybe publish or
maybe present to somebody else
now we hope that in that context you
will also get exposed to some of the
useful coding practices that
are typically used for reproducible
research but also for teamwork
so oftentimes you will have to share
your code with somebody else and they
will have to navigate
what is in the code what was done so
we'll talk about how to use
comments how to organize your code how
to
run functions and how to call the
functions with different
parameters that you need to have that
function work
we'll talk about how to troubleshoot
your code and
kind of understand what the issues mean
and where do they come from
how to find the answers we'll also talk
about sharing your analysis
in jupiter notebooks on github and
google collab
and we'll take some examples so that we
can also prepare some visual
interactive visualizations using
plotlink
now in the context of the program we
will go through several
example data sets and all of these data
sets come from our reviewed set of
projects
these projects have been reviewed for
some conceptual approaches which relate
to
different types of machine learning
methods or different
molecular biology or precision medicine
topic so we will really take a look at
how
the biological or the application side
connects with the types of
methods that were used and for which
purpose we will also
understand how the algorithmic part
or how the analysis part fits in to some
of the challenges that are being
presented
and how do these algorithms actually
address the problem by
integration classification and
predictive analysis
now we do have a lot of different
project examples already
you'll be able to find all of these
project examples
on our portal and so this brings me to
how this program is actually going to
work the way it will work is we will
have
interactive sessions like today i will
pause in a second and we'll actually
interact so i'll
ask you questions and ask you to do
certain things we will also
rely on some self-guided study materials
these study materials are organized
in specific lessons and courses that
will be useful for this program
but also they will include some
practical assignments and so
in a moment i will guide you through
some of the resources that you need to
have access to
to benefit from this program the most
how many of you already have an account
on learn omixlogic.com so please put
number one
in your chat
if you do have an account if you do not
have an account okay thank you then
please go to learn
omixlogic.com
okay i see that a lot of you already
have an account
so let's go to this account
together okay if you do not have an
account this is what we need to
do next so this is the portal as i
mentioned
learn omixlogic.com i'll give a moment
to everyone who's just joining us for
the first time to create an account how
do you create an account
you will find on top of this menu
a button to log in
and so once you are here you can create
an account
okay so i will wait a minute
for those of you that do not have an
account yet
to create an account and once you do
please log in
for the others that are
already registered please sign in
and go to your profile
okay okay i see some people are signing
in
okay excellent so once you are in
you should be able to see your email
address right here on top
and when you click on this you have
a user id now because this program is
supported by the louisiana biomedical
research
network or lbrn for those of you that
are here and are a part of the program
i ask that you copy this url
and put it right here in the chat box
okay so that way we can have a registry
of everyone who is participating in
today's session
and who is either joining the program
already or is planning to join because
today is our first session
so please share the link to your profile
if you don't want others to see it you
can do it directly to me
okay thank you navnit
all right excellent thank you everyone
so i'll just again give just a couple of
minutes for everyone to
share that link thank you madeline
and rebecca i
okay excellent thank you everyone
now especially for those of you that are
part of the louisiana biomedical
research
network we do need for you to
fill in you need to create a profile you
don't have to use your personal image
you can use
any image that you want you can also put
in a little bit of a bio
right here by clicking on edit profile
and i will explain
why this is going to be useful for those
of you that are part of the
summer research program with the
louisiana biomedical research network
all right thank you hidayah durba
amrit all right great
so as you go through this program
you will see that all of your activity
is being logged and this is to help you
see your progress and understand where
you are
compared to where this program is taking
you the objective of this program
is to get you to 10 000 points so you
can see that i just crossed over ten
thousand points not so long ago
so whenever you get to ten thousand
points is when you can start
working on an independent project which
is really the objective
of this program as well it's not only
just to learn but also to be able to
apply what you learn
to a data set that you find and create
either a project proposal or work on a
complete project on your own
here you will find the different
coursework that
is available and that you are working
through so that means that you are
completing the project
like i completed this project and sorry
this
course and i can see my certificate and
some of them i just started so you can
see that they're
zero percent some of them i'm working on
also for those of you that have already
registered and i noticed a few of you
from the lbrn did not yet have an
account
now it's important because now that i
have your account information i will be
able to add you
to the program so the program that we
are in
is lbr and omix logic data science
so if you go to this program link i will
share the link
in our chat if you have
already completed your registration to
this program
this is what you should be able to see
you should be able to see your profile
see here the overview of the program
which is right here
see the coursework included in this
program and these are the courses that
we intend to go through
you will also see that you can book a
meeting to discuss with us any
challenges
you will have access to our slack
channel where you can ask
questions from our support team and also
get to know the other participants of
the program
and finally once you complete 10
sessions of this program
you will receive a certificate about
your participation
how do you know that you've completed a
session
so down at the bottom underneath this
overview
you will find the program schedule in
the program schedule
you will find a zoom link so you know
how to join today's session for example
and you also have this button that says
complete session
so once you press on complete session it
says session completed
down here you can see that now i have
one out of 10 sessions complete
so every time that we have a session
like today you complete them
and that means that you can work towards
your certificate
now in addition to this as i mentioned
we will have some
asynchronous materials for you to work
through that include some
active uh learning which will include
some
coding exercises and practical exercises
including
quizzes so that will help you understand
what you have learned
what you still don't know and where do
you need to focus for
you to really master data science for
biomedical discovery
so what are these courses down below
these are some of the coursework that we
will plan to complete
during this program first of all i would
like to ask all of you to go to
introduction to bioinformatics this is
an important course
not just because i'm assuming that all
of you do not
know about bioinformatics i'm sure that
most of you already know something about
bioinformatics
however this course also allows us to
get to know
about you and so in the first lesson
you will find here's a survey on your
background
educational background including your
bioinformatics experience
and what you are interested in so that
will help us adapt our materials more
to your needs
so let me pause here for a second does
anyone have any questions so far
if you do have any questions feel free
to post them
in the chat
okay so no questions so far so i'm
assuming that
everything is very clear so the first
thing that we talked
about is that we have this online
repository of asynchronous resources on
learnxlogic.com
those will include some coursework but
also thank you dr
candice as well that includes some
coursework
and some practical project examples that
you can start seeing how to apply some
of these methods
to real challenges also we talked about
our
personal profile on the personal profile
if you would be able to complete your
image
for your profile write a little bit
about yourself
you will see here points accumulating
and
you importantly will find here a
subscription so for those of you that
are
joining the program you will need
a starter subscription which is
different from the basic
that means that you have access to
premium courses
and you will have a badge that badge
will correlate
will be from your program so this
program is called lbrand data science
if you don't have those what i will do
today after the session is go through
the
profiles that you have submitted and if
you are
in the list from lbrn we will assign you
to that program so you will gain access
to all the resources
if you do not have it and you're not a
part of lbrn and you're waiting to join
please proceed to the program page you
will find their directions on
registration
is asking will i share these recorded
videos as well
so we have our program page let me just
show you
the program page again
so if i go to my profile and i'm
registered for this program
i can go to the program page and
then here after this session is
over and the recording is posted you
will find the recording right here
and then the next session will become a
zoom link so
everyone who's a part of this program
will have access to all of the recorded
sessions
and we will also guide you through some
asynchronous materials that you can
complete
okay all right so hopefully that's
enough about the program if you do have
any other questions
post your questions in the chat box or
if you have those questions after the
session please use slack
we have a dedicated slack channel for
this
you can find the slack channel by going
all the way to the bottom
and click on ask a question it will
redirect you
to slack so on slack
we have a dedicated channel again for
the program participants
and you will be able to ask questions
for example i posted today the zoom
meeting link right here
all right so there are no other
questions i would like to introduce you
to clinton cunha clinton has
a master's degree in molecular medicine
as well as
in bioinformatics and is
experienced in different aspects of data
science including
linux programming r and python
and so i will turn it over to you
clinton to take it from here thank you
thank you elia so today we're going to
go over some introductory
python and r that helps you that will
help you
load different data sets
into your own programs so could i get
just a rough um idea if most of you have
an ide installed on your computer so
maybe put a one or put a one
if you have either r or visual studio
code installed on your computer
okay nice
nice if if not it's fine
we we can also go over nice okay
if not it's fine we will also go over
how to install that
um through the tutorial so
let's start off with um our programming
okay
so if everyone could go to their course
page
so to go to this course page you'd have
to go to this link
i'll paste it in the chat
and then we have to scroll through the
courses
you can also type it um
and let's scroll to r coding one getting
started with bioinformatics
okay so if you can click this link
and then click the first um lesson
loading data in
r okay i'll give everyone
just a second to catch up
perfect so there is a tutorial on how to
download
r in rstudio um
we can go over it near the end of the
session but most of the activities that
we'll do today
will be on the website itself
but if you don't have our insta or
rstudio installed
or an ide similar for python
please reach out to us and we can also
help you step by step with how to
install it
okay so i'm i prefer visual studio code
just because i find it more user user
friendly compared to
pycharm and other ides but everyone has
their own
preference i would recommend starting
off with visual studio code for python
just because it's very user friendly
okay so
hopefully um so you can take a moment to
read through this
so this is essentially giving you an
introduction of r
and r is not only limited to biomedical
data but other
um facets of the industry also use
r for statistical analysis so it's a
very
handy programming language to have
because it's a
it's a data science tool
okay so after you
you went through the um a little
description of what r
is we can jump to how to put in
files within r so
maybe you have different types of data
files whether it's txt
csv files um
uh yeah uh yeah most of those
are the common formats that we use and
you can specify different
coding blocks or coding statements to
read that particular file
so over here if you want to import
and view a specific file into r
use a function known as read table and
it does have some extra
parameters here this tells you
how you want the columns to be separated
and header equals true tells you
if the first row means uh the headers of
those particular columns so depending on
the type of data set you have
you do you might want to put header
equals false
or header equals true
so you can take a few i'll give everyone
around two three minutes just to read
over this
and then we'll do the practical
um coding exercises right below okay
so take a moment just to read this
material and get a sense of what's going
on
and if you have questions please write
it in the chat
specific questions as you read along so
i'll give you
around two minutes so two three minutes
to read this one
yeah yeah that's true so sometimes um
sometimes yeah code sounds better in our
heads sometimes
but while we do it uh there seems to be
like
different issues that arise so i i can
completely relate to that example
and depending on your coding experience
there's a very
uh
oh so that's
that's a common thing with programmers
in the sense that
you know sometimes they have an idea in
their head
but they need like they might google
things or go on stack overflow
different websites to piece it together
so
you i think that like some people
joke around with programmers by calling
them great googlers
so it's if you know the fundamental
pieces
and figure out how to put them together
then you can
build on those small steps for bigger
projects
so you know if you do feel nervous
don't worry this is this isn't meant to
be
a super diff intensive and difficult
course it's
it gradually builds up and there's an
asynchronous part to it
so most it starts off with simpler
exercises
and then builds up to more advanced
topics so
yeah yeah every every programmer starts
with a
or data scientist slash analyst slash
programmer
starts with a more simpler um
method of coding okay
okay so if you don't see
if you do not see r let me just
go back to the that portion
i i'm getting some messages that some
people can't see this
particular module
so back to the courses page
if you scroll down go to number two
and you should see an option saying
getting started with bioinformatics are
coding
hopefully the person who could not see
this
can maybe clarify whether they can see
it
okay so here is the r coding part
r coding one getting started with
bioinformatics
and then all you have to do perfect
awesome great
no problem okay then you click that
and then you click loading data in r
over here so you click
that the first module
and then you should see the different
the different parts to it so there are
four parts and i gave
everyone around two minutes just to read
this aspect
so we can try it we can try it now okay
so let's go to the next part try it
yourself
so over here essentially what you're
doing
is you have a diff you have a data set
over here
it's we put it up for you and you have
to copy that data set
and read it into your own into
this online ide
and then it will print that data set for
you so
over here i right click here and i click
copy link address
and then i should put that link address
into this code right here
so i click paste uh make sure you
keep the quotes okay so the quotes
should be there
and then you should run that particular
uh snippet
okay so what we're doing here is we're
reading
this text file directly into r
okay and we're separating each column
by the tabs that um separate each column
so we specify
this uh backs uh forward slash
t and the header is the first row of
that file so
if you if you click that file here you
can see the first
the first row is the header of that data
set
and then each of the columns are
separated by huge tabs
so if there were commas between
these columns you'd you'd have to put
comma
instead of tab okay can someone ask
answer the question if if there were
periods between
the columns what might you have to put
here
if if there weren't tabs there were just
periods what would you
make as a separator
yeah perfect yes
so right now the separators tabs because
as you can see they're large tabs
between each of the
different columns so there's one piece
of data here and one piece of data
but instead if there weren't tabs and
there were other types of separators
like periods or commas then we might
want to change that into
a the relevant separator
okay so perfect
so for commas it depends on your data
set so
a lot of people depending on
their research methodology they might
not keep their data clean
so this is a very great example of clean
data
but some data they they might
they might not spell specimen correctly
for all of the
specimen words or they might have
uh they might not have equal tabs
between everything
and there might be a period here but no
period there so
you'd use a p you'd use a comma if
there's a clear separation
between the columns with a comma but
over here
there's a tab that separates the columns
so
in this case you would use a tab but in
other cases you'd use a comma or a
period
um what's the default that's that's a
great question
um let me jump in here real quick
so as you can see in the future code
blocks below
there are different options to read you
can read csv
which is specifically for comma you can
read
table where you need to specify you can
read
excel sx which you need a special
package for
so these are really different examples
but in our case
what's important is that you first
identify what is the type of file i have
and then based on what the type of data
you have you choose which option you
need to use yeah yeah that's a that's a
great um
that's a great explanation yep so yeah
depending on the type
of file you have so over here we use xa
xls over here we use csv
and you copy please take a moment to
copy
these links and paste them into the path
name
so you can see how this
exactly works and click run so over here
we're using a library to help us
read.xls this function
reads xls files directly
and then we get our
our our data set printed on the console
okay take some uh take a few moments to
read to go through this
and if you if you do have r
into installed you can even copy
that relevant code and run it on your r
studio so over here
you can put the same since it's a url
that also works and you can read the
table
or you can download the data set onto
your laptop
or computer and change the path name
so if this is the exact same thing on
the website but on your my local machine
so you can also do something similar
we can go through the steps of
downloading
r and rstudio near the end of the uh the
lesson
but for now just focus on the
online content and try to make those
examples work
and let me know if you have any
questions if you're stuck trying to run
some of these code snippets
and here are some extra files that you
can run
so here's this is a nice enlarged data
set
so this is a breast cancer data set
and it has different labels and error
classes
and along with their g numbers
and you can you can read these files
into uh your
your code here in a similar way so
paste that csv read.csv that should work
great oh oh yeah because this one
the answer is incorrect because it's
expecting the data set up here
but uh it's it's still reading the file
okay and there's a
there's another oh okay
so if if anyone just to reiterate uh
what we're trying to do here is we're
trying to
read different types of files into r
okay instead of downloading the the r
programming language onto your computer
right now
we're we're reading these files onto
our uh online our code console
okay so you instead of having this this
on my on your current screen we're
running the exact same thing
onto the online console so you don't
have to install r right now
but we can we will go through the steps
um after
near the end of the lesson after going
through some of these online
coding exercises so
i didn't mention that everyone should
take a few moments to read this
uh snippet to get it get a sense of what
we're doing
and essentially to summarize what this
is saying
is we are learning how to read
different file formats such as excel
files
text files csv files
into r using a variety of commands
so some of the commands include
read.table
for txt files
xls x for
excel files csv
read.csv for csv files
so these are three different commands to
read
three different file types so depending
on
because this is a data science course
you will probably encounter these
file types when you're analyzing
different types of data
um so you you do need to understand
at least the code syntax and how to do
this
on your for your own future data sets
i hope i hope that clarifies the concept
and if uh there's someone that did
message me and i hope that clarifies it
if you could message me
back indicating if that
gave you some clarity that would be
appreciated
okay so these are just extra
txt csv and excel files to try
to run over here and you can copy the
same code
and run it in your own rstudio if you
have it
so here i i use the direct link
to code omics but you can also download
it into your own system
and copy that particular path name so
like over here i have i have these test
files
and then you open up your properties
and you you copy your path
and you paste your path over here
however
the the the brackets
are different so instead of these
brackets you have to use back
backslashes okay so the way
r and also python reads path names is
that they read it through backslashes
so i won't go into this too much because
some of you might not have are
installed so i'm going to skip this for
now but we're going to talk about how to
install our later on
okay so
hopefully uh could i get a indication
could you write a one if
most of you have tried these exercises
online and
hopefully they're working could could i
get a one
perfect perfect
okay okay we'll um okay
let me let me help you for one example
and hopefully
not sure where to try oh okay uh okay
maybe you
so to try this particular example
click number two down here
so there there you have to be on this
website
so i'll copy this
okay and then you have to click
page number two okay
and then you need to click r coding one
getting started with bioinformatics so
you have to click that
and then then you click
loading data in our perfect great great
great
and it for uh rebecca um
for the first exercise over here
uh please click this button here so you
have a few options down here
so you can copy your code with this you
can reset your code
you can clear the console with this so
please right click the here over here so
you can get
open link to new tab open link in new
window
and click copy link address okay
when you click copy link address you're
going to copy the path
for the the location of the here file
okay and once you copy the path
take a moment to highlight the the path
that's in the console over here or in
the
script over here and then
right click and paste that path
so do you have something like this on
your screen
yes okay perfect yes perfect and then
click
run
did you see a lot of confetti fly all
over the screen
yeah okay perfect awesome
great great yeah that's uh well yeah
we don't have oh okay that's interesting
because yeah if you click
run you should say completed and the
answer is correct and you should have
some confetti flying
in the screen maybe it might be a
browser specific thing
but it's fine that's uh that's just an
extra fun component of the code
okay so great so most of you did this
and you can uh you can click complete
and put your
put some feedback on the complexity of
this
uh this is meant to be easy to get you
into the coding
like habit and to get the data set
you're interested in
so now after doing that let's jump to
python okay i i personally
i i like python more than r but that's
just a personal opinion i i just
i feel like it's just there's more
versatility but that's just me
okay so
you can go to
i think i believe it's in three no right
no it's in one sorry so go to one
and click get getting started with
bioinformatics in python
so this is this is the course that we're
gonna do now so click
this
okay and then click loading data right
here
okay
okay so these are some instructions
to download python on your own system
just like the r course had some
instructions
there's also a python equivalent so
you can take some time to install this
on your system
but preferably we'll do it later on
or because of the time constraints of
the session
but we will help you with it if you do
have issues
okay so that the first part is about
installing your ide and python so you
have to do both
and then please take around two to three
minutes
just to read the learn the code portion
because this is important
uh some of this it's it's good to read
through what's going on to get a clear
idea and then we'll implement it
in real time so
two i'll give you three minutes so
please take three minutes to read this
you
okay so could someone type
the extensions of the files that we're
going to load in
with python what are what are the names
of the extensions
that we're talking about for today's
session
you can type the three side by side in
the chat
great great yeah perfect perfect just
like the r module
we're going to learn how to load xls
files
csv files and text files so these are
these are some common file formats to
that are available for different that
data sets are available in
perfect so
there's one key difference here between
the way
the python module works and the way the
r module works
so the r module is more memory intensive
so you you have we
our auto grader takes your code input
and sends it to a google cloud server
and compiles the code over there
and returns the output back to the
online coding system
however python is less memory intensive
and it can be handled within the the
your google chrome browser therefore
we can directly install some packages
over here
and we can actively run the code on this
browser so that's one key difference
to the way we'll put in files within
this
uh module so let's see what that means
in practice
so if everyone can take a moment to
import
pandas and numpy so these are two
data science packages in python that are
useful for
uh data curation so maybe please take a
moment to click
run and have in this might take a little
bit of time
to import these packages onto your
system
okay and
one key thing about this module
is that um
uh i can't okay for some reason i cannot
annotate
but we are going to load the file down
here
into the drop file over here so the code
runs
from top to bottom so before you run
this
code command you need to run this code
or you need to download this text file
and drop it over here
and also specify the name of that text
file
in the code block so i'll show you what
that means in practice
so let's say i have this
file over here so i click it over here
and let me save it somewhere so
let me save as i'm going to save it here
i have a folder here test files it's
already there
you want to replace it yes i'm going to
replace it okay
so i'm going to show this in my folder
my folder is right here okay
so i have this data set right here so if
i go back
to this portion
i open this test files folder and i drag
this text file into drop a file you see
how this changes color
so you bring it over here until it
changes color to just
orange and then you drop the file inside
and then you should notice that it
dropped because you see
the name of the file inside this box
okay so then you can copy the name of
this file
and then you can put it in this location
so i'm going to reset this code
just so it okay i guess this is was
already reset
and then if it looks the same
just paste that particular
um file name within the quotes
and then run this run the script so
right now
you're importing and viewing a text file
and then you should see the names of the
columns
and the uh the values
on the console okay
so hopefully everyone's can everyone do
that
can can everyone put a one in the chat
just to see if that's working
because the rest of the exercises depend
on
one
okay it seems like we're still doing it
so that's fine
okay so essentially you download the
file
with the the here link over here
and then you open the folder location of
that file
and then you you drag that file into the
drop a file portion
and then you should see the file name
pop up to the right over here
and then you copy that file name and you
put it
in this in the single quotes and then
you should click
run so then your
code will run
okay perfect perfect
so in python um
they instead of them saying
data frame they use pd and it's it's
in reference to this package so this
package
helps you visualize
data frames in python so a data frame is
just a fancy way
it's it's just a fancy word for the way
this data looks
this is a data frame so it you know with
with columns and rows so that's what
that's what essentially is happening in
python
but it doesn't look as graphically uh
appealing as this on r but it's the same
thing
okay and the same
sort of parameters of plywood uh
over here the tab and the
header equals zero portion okay
and please take a moment to try
the other two exercises down here
so this this is for a csv file
and in this csv file you're you have to
do the same process
so you copy you click here you download
your file
your data set you sh you have it in your
downloads folder
sorry so you have your your downloads
folder right here
oops ah there it goes my okay so you
have your downloads folder right
here and then you copy
you you can drag it directly from
downloads
into the next portion up here
and then you should have the file name
here and you copy it
and then paste it down here
okay and then you click you should click
run and then it should work
okay so take a moment to
go through this try
okay yeah so this is done great
and then we'll go over this data types
portion
so here you can click this file download
the data frame uh data types so they're
different data types in python
so it could be numerical or text and
amongst others
we'll we'll see it over here
if you click the the location of this
file
in your downloads folder please
drag it back to the dropper
file so this drop of file is for this
next portion
and then click run
and then it should you should see
different types of
data types over here so you have
uh float values
and uh it says oh uh this one
is it should be a text to my knowledge
but let me um let me
double check i i believe it's text
sorry
yeah so the data frame one is the float
means the numbers on the right
the 23 point the the ones with the
decimal
but o should specify the specimen name
okay so if if you have uh
data types with text and numbers uh
num uh pandas uses the o operator
so if i open that data set
um that i just downloaded
uh right here
so yeah so the first column has
text and numbers so that's why it's an
old data type so it has a mix of both
so that's why lumpy
detected it or pandas detected it as a
oh data type which is a mix of both
where do you uh where do you click
download uh
oh so here if you click here
if you click this button the file should
pop up in your downloads folder
but uh that's that's how it is for most
computers but
maybe in your computer you set it to a
different one so
if i click here it
i have the file downloaded on the bottom
and then if i click show in folder it's
in my downloads folder
so my downloads folder is here it says
users me and the downloads
so it would be right here
okay perfect
take a moment to try some some of these
extra
data sets so you can try the text file
the csv file
and this function essentially
uh just it it prints the topmost
um rows for your uh
your data set so if i were to run this
portion so let's say
i know i didn't put my file in sorry so
let's uh
here's my 15 genes
oh sorry about that i'm not sure what
happened i think
too much data on my computer sorry about
that
um so yeah when i download this file
i drag it up here and i copy this
here i put
that over here and i run it
okay so i it's when you have errors it's
good to sometimes
clear your console and rerun the
the portion so you can see it so the the
head
okay so don't worry uh we're almost done
uh i just wanted to finish up with this
coating exercise
so this is the head portion and then
this is to read this format and
and this is just to show you the first
five rows
of the 15 csv files or the 15 rows of
the csv file
so great so this is the practical coding
session for today
but we'll do harder and more complex
things later
i'll now pass it on to ilia to talk more
to finish off the
today's session all right thank you very
much clinton and hopefully
everybody found this useful to
understand
how to do some of the basics let me
briefly
explain what is coming up next where is
this program going
so the first part of the program is
going to be introductory
introductory means that today we covered
omix data types and properties
and we briefly discussed how to load
them
now we will talk about big data
challenges and opportunities as you've
seen these are very small data sets
so then we will talk about where do we
find real data
how big is it and what are some of the
challenges associated with
extracting meaningful information from
them as well as what are some of the
opportunities with so many data
repositories growing out there
how is this going to be useful for you
then we'll talk about cleaning loading
and processing data
we'll talk about exploratory data
analysis how do we explore what are the
different patterns
and how do we find interesting patterns
that are
signal and not noise then we will talk
about
how practically speaking in your own
environment
do you set this environment so that you
can handle
large and complex data and so that will
mean how do you combine
access to cloud computing some of the
requirements for your own personal
system where do you store files how do
you store them how do you organize them
and how to start loading all of these
libraries into your own system so you
can run it
and then also where is this output going
to be so how do you organize the outputs
from your pipelines
and how do you actually make sense of
uh the steps that you need to be taking
from the beginning to the end
in the second part of this program we
will start talking about
machine learning and artificial
intelligence so
machine learning in general is divided
up into
unsupervised and supervised machine
learning and there are many different
methods out there that are typically
used for analysis of large and complex
data sets
and what we need to understand is first
of all what is the logic
between behind what we want to do
and what the method can do and then how
do we
also combine some of these different
machine learning methods
to get us what we actually need we then
will talk
about how in supervised analysis or
classification we can train a model
based on a data set that we've prepared
and then
test the understanding of the model of
what is
in the data with some validation
so we'll talk about model accuracy how
do we measure
rock curves and in area under curve and
then how do we compare different models
in terms of
what they're able to give us and then
finally we'll talk about
how to actually get results with machine
learning so machine learning
is not analysis a sense that i get data
i analyze it i have results
machine learning is best used when we
have continuous
data that we have to deal with and so
there's a whole process
of setting up pipelines for machine
learning and
monitoring them so that is something
that we will cover
and in our next session as you can see
here we will talk
about big data challenges and
opportunities to kind of
take us past this initial step
now uh for those of you that
join today and do not have
the r studio or visual
code this would be the important step
before we meet next time and also
i would highly recommend finishing
introduction to bioinformatics
and some of these practical initial
steps now if you didn't register yet
that is fine
you will see that most of this sessions
course is free so you can kind of
participate in everything that we do
if you do want to join our next session
you have to complete your registration
before then
and please have your visual studio
and your r studio installed if you
face any challenges do let us know
before we meet so you can email us
uh or you can let us know um
kisembo i will definitely talk to our
marketing team
to send you uh the paypal option we can
try that as well
uh but unless anyone else has any other
specific
uh questions okay thank you clinton
homework for next time complete
introduction to our an introduction to
python
so introduction to bioinformatics in our
introduction to bioinformatics and
python
and also the course introduction to
bioinformatics
and now we have another
10 minutes left for those that do not
have visual studio code in python or
rstudio installed
so if you do have challenges with that
maybe you can stay and we can
walk you through or answer any questions
about that
if you don't have any questions
everything was clear today
you're ready please complete your
profile start working on that coursework
and we will see you next uh this friday
clinton i will leave it up to you if
anyone has
any issues installing those right okay
yeah yeah
i i i'm ready for it
all right so the only thing that we need
to know is who has
issues and um and then we can help them
all right well thank you everyone we'll
see you next time
so okay
yeah so you're welcome to to leave
if you don't have issues
but if you have programming and other
course related issues
please stay and we can go over them or
try to get through
thank you for attending everybody see
you guys
soon
okay so i'm i'm assuming everyone here
either has an issue downloading rstudio
or r
or um python in
visual studio code or pycharm or some
other ide
so could you put a one if you have an
issue with that it's
yeah this is meant to be
the the first intro course so don't feel
shy if you
yeah perfect perfect
okay uh let's start off with uh
let's start off with our studio and then
we'll
jump to python okay
okay so good old google
is my friend so
first thing we need to do is install the
r programming language so
our programming language is
dull so this is independent
of um
our uh this is independent of our studio
so if everyone can i'll paste the link
in the chat as well
[Music]
so if you're uh
oh okay any mac users
i don't think it should be an issue but
if you if you're a mac user
okay great uh let's let's try to
figure that out one second
song mac yeah i'm a windows user myself
so
we're going to have to yes okay this is
yes this is r for mac os so you'd you'd
want to choose
uh you'd want to choose the first one
this one
okay this is directly from the r website
[Music]
so so this won't work for me because i'm
a
i'm a windows user so we're going to
have to um
work figure that out together okay
see this is it's a good one
okay let's see don's mac installing
our website i think i believe it's yeah
it's the same website we went to
and yeah it's the same link but this is
an older version of our so you have to
click
the link i send you you still have to
click this
and then there are a couple of
installation
instructions that you have to follow in
mac
so if you want you can share your screen
we can do that one at a time
so yeah that's an option okay
so so first download this file
and then after you've downloaded it you
should be able to
uh click on that file and it should
download
into your computer so it should be like
a dot exe
on windows and it should automatically
guide you through the steps and accept
the default options
so we're not we the default options
are fine for our purpose and
most people install the default options
so let me know your progress the mac
users installing are because
um just let me know what's going on
whether it's like you can write a little
statement or you can even
you can even talk like use your audio
and tell me what's going on
okay
perfect great okay now you have
r on your system okay now you need
rstudio
so our studio is it's the ide
for r so
uh our studio download mac say
okay you're downloading perfect so
rstudio
and you want to choose the free version
uh
okay this is for windows
it's windows 10 right here so this is
this is the operating system that you
want so it says mac
os 10 plus i'll send you the link as
well
okay so let me click yeah if i click
download it brings me down here
and it should tell you your recommended
uh settings so i'll paste this link in
the chat as well
okay but if it doesn't pop off here this
is the one you'd want to use for a mac
okay perfect so that that's pretty much
r in our studio um
python's a little bit i wouldn't say
it's tricky but it depends on the type
of ide you want because there
are different ones out there um
oh yeah let me know if if that works for
you when you download uh
r and r studio so try
try some sample code from today's lesson
and hopefully it will work
and here's the python link to download
python
so it does say different you know python
for windows python for linux
python for mac so you'd want to click
you know mac and then you know you'd
want to click
one of these you can click intel
this is fine intel is fine
okay so this is for mac
and once you downloaded uh that
i'll give you some time because it does
you know it's because it's probably
installing
etc in terms of your ide this one's a
this one's an open question in the sense
that you might have your own preferences
i'm going to recommend the one that
we use like biotech and i personally
like to use it's visual studio code so
visual studio code
you click that and then
it should have your two your options
here so mac os
so i'm going to paste the link here
okay so yeah let me know uh
hopefully let me know your progress uh
with everything so far you guys can
maybe run some of this
sample code this is python sample code
oh well you might want to change the
path
and i'll give you guys some r sample
code
uh sorry this r code should work because
it's an
online link so the r code
is on the bottom that should work but
the the python code you
you have to change the the path
so this is my local directory so you'd
want to change
it to your own
so let me know if you have questions or
if i'm going too fast
every everything okay uh purity
p joseph kasembo
allu wade milad dr candice
and rebecca how's everything
good everything installed yeah
oh you're installing all right
downloading
nice nice yes
nice okay great if you can run the
sample code in your system that means
everything is all set to go and uh
you're free to leave so you're done for
the installation part
so good job joseph
i will see you next time or next session
hopefully all right
yeah i i personally like visual studio
code because
i like the way they color code
everything it just easier
easy to understand and read
so yeah if if you can run the sample
code in both
your systems then you're all set but let
me know if you have any
particular questions
okay
yeah let me know your uh progress um
and i'll help you if you're stuck
yeah this parts the more technical part
and
makes sense if it's very important
though
nice nice so i guess r is working for
you rebecca hopefully
yeah take that as a
well
okay
this oh okay
uh yeah uh maybe uh
if you yeah so i think
which which one python or r so
r or it's fine if you say both
but r should work because it's uh
so let me let me replace the r codes so
this
this should work but let me uh
let me format it in the right way to let
me show you how
it needs to be written so
[Music]
so it needs to be written like this
so you can you can get rid of that that
might confuse you
so this part is how it should be written
so this this part this is extra code
but you this is how it should be written
so let me know if that works and if it
doesn't
still let me know
okay yes r is gonna work awesome
python it might not work uh and the
reason for that
is because you need your exact path and
the way you write your path you need to
write it
in um you need to write it in a way that
it's backslashes
so you can copy the path name on your
to your file so let's say um
i go to desktop test files so this is
where all my files are located
so then you go up here this is the path
so you copy that path
and then you paste it over here
so this path needs to be put
within the quotes the the single quotes
okay but this
all the slashes have to change
orientation
so it can't be like this this is for all
your future parts as well
it needs to be the opposite orientation
okay it just it just it's just like that
so
that's just the way it is that's that's
how it reads
okay so you change that
slash and then it should work
okay take a moment to try that
okay so how's everyone else doing i i
only
only candace responded so i assume
everybody else is doing okay if you
finish
then you're free to leave so
but if you're struggling please let me
know
okay no no that's it rebecca we just uh
wanted to make sure you have the ides
and the programming languages installed
and you can run them comfortably on your
computer
so now technically you're already a
programmer because you ran this so
congrats to you um you're you're
you're good for that part so you're free
to leave rebecca
so i'll see you next session or the
session afterwards
no problem see you
so how's everyone else doing to symbol
allu weidi milad purity
okay
all right awesome
yeah all right so you've it works on
your computer because zombo
python
yeah fireworks oh okay
uh i guess yeah
uh please install python as well and uh
oh not yet
do you know how how they do it [ __ ] do
you remember the steps or
no oh okay yeah well i'll are you a mac
user or a
windows user
mac oh so
check out this link um
so open this link and uh
sorry on a second
and click click this mac os
6 64-bit installer
so that's the python portion
okay and then
and then after you click that you need
to click
i'll send you the visual studio code so
you have to install two things
so after you click that then you have to
click mac os
stable for visual studio code
so this this part on the screen
okay
so how's everyone else doing i only hear
kasembo and
dr candice but i i don't know what
purity and
although what a millen is up to
[Music]
okay i think i think maybe
check if your quotes are correct
and check if everything's backslash
and make sure your text file
is this name so after the
the upmost directory then you have a
backslash
and then you have the name of the file
that you're trying to open
so this is the name of the file you're
trying to open this is the location to
that file
and then you it has to be in quotes
and it has to it has to literally look
like
what's on my screen so like every
every part has to literally look like
this
okay accept the path sorry except the
path the path is different for your
computer but
the name the name
depending on the file you use can also
be different
okay so this is the path to your file
up to here and then this is the actual
name of the text file that you're going
to use
okay so hopefully how's that going
is it working for you now dr candace or
almost on the right track
are you still getting the same error
you're getting closer if you yeah if you
feel comfortable you can also share your
screen
okay yeah that's programming welcome to
program
so yeah if you feel comfortable you can
share your screen
you don't have to but that might speed
up the process
so it has to look exactly like my screen
except the path needs to be different
so everything here needs to be the same
oh okay okay uh
try now i think you should be able to
yeah you should yeah you should be able
to
to share now so yeah perfect
okay
oh okay so you didn't download visual
studio code yet
okay so visual studio code
is uh
you need to use that okay
because the reason for that is
i'll tell you why so
how would i say this
so did you try downloading visual studio
code yet
so right now i see the idl shell
so
so let me let me show you what i'm
talking about
okay i'm just gonna show you what i mean
okay so what you have
is this so right now you're here
so what you want is a more user-friendly
environment
so here this stuff doesn't really
doesn't work as as you think it would
work
okay over here you might have to do one
thing at a time
so so this yeah see this stuff
some of this stuff won't work okay so
don't you know what don't stress about
this part
um let me do a simple thing
can you write prints hello
can you write that does that work for
you let me know if that works for you
because
right now you don't have visual studio
code installed
so you didn't install this yet so you
have to click
this stable down here this blue link
so i'll give you this website
and you need to install that blue link
that blue arrow down here
because you're a mac user so you need to
install that
that that's one reason why it's not
working another reason
is uh so you know what
you this one you don't need that part
this part
is fine there's some extra packages
uh where's python right here
here let me see if it can work from the
way you have it
as no see it won't it will never work
that way unfortunately
because you need to install different
packages
so for that part you know as long as you
have visual studio code
and python installed on your system that
should be the main part
um beyond that
so if you want to install this
you need to write this on the the bottom
parts
so don't worry about this too much
but that's that's what you should write
and you should also write
uh this
so this is installing the packages but
you have to have visual studio code
first
so you need this thing first so the
thing that you have
is this one that's what i saw but you
want
visual studio code you want this thing
they look different right you
so one's more not graphically friendly
the other one's more graphically
[Music]
friendly that make sense
uh doctor candace
so once you
so you can share your screens right yes
awesome great
okay now click create a new file
so there should be a
yeah you can uh i guess you can
you can click open folder or there's on
the bottom is there not a
create new file somewhere
there's no create new file option okay
let me let me open my version
and see
there should be a file on the top right
a file option top
i mean top left sorry top left there
should be a file option
and you should click file and then new
file
all right that's top right sorry top
left
is there not a file option on the top
left
oh no i guess it's not there that's
weird oh no because you're a mac user so
you have to go up to the
like where you normally see file and all
that stuff there's a
there's a toolbar up top yeah perfect
and then you select your language click
select language
then click python so type python sorry
yeah click there
okay and now uh it says you want to
recommend yeah
install it yeah yeah so this is just
it's it's an extension of python into
visual studio code
it just helps support uh
it's uh it just
adds more uh options for your down
your future python coding practices
so you can go back to untitled so back
to
top top all the way up to welcome where
there's welcome
top left welcome untitled extension
python get started
i wish i could annotate it won't let me
so
you see the imagine the topmost part of
your
tab yeah yeah welcome you saw it welcome
you just passed it
yeah go to the right you see untitled
yes
and now save this file just like you did
um you opened a new file on the top left
save this somewhere
okay and save it as a python file
it says all files but click click all
files and save it as a
yeah python and name it whatever you
want
okay perfect uh it says
you have selected so click select python
interpreter
and click uh the last one delay
3.96 there you go that one
perfect and now you can copy
the code that i gave you earlier so i'll
recopy it for you
okay here it that won't work because
you're missing quotes
and i'll copy the exact same code that i
gave
you earlier
so here's the the code from earlier
i paste it in the chat so
get rid of all the lines there and paste
the code i have
except no keep your path name sorry
because you want to copy the path into
the code i put it in the chat
okay
so yeah
go go to the zoom chat yeah perfect
great
get rid of the yeah the df in the yeah
so i would i would copy
go to um go to import pandas
and make that a new line start from the
i for inline two
and yeah click there and press enter
perfect
and now copy that path name from the
the backslash or from that slash just
the path
okay everything in the quotes yeah okay
that too you have to copy that
and paste it in the bottom path yeah
and now put a single quote in the
beginning of that backslash on the
bottom
uh before before the slash put a single
quote
okay now change all the slashes to
a backslash they're all forward slashes
you need to change all of them to
backslashes
okay and now get rid of the number line
and
uh number one and two get rid of those
two lines
uh line one no no that's line two three
and four
yeah yeah perfect line one and two get
rid of that you don't need that
okay click that green arrow on the top
right
yeah click that so
click it one more okay okay now go to
the bottom where it says candice macbook
pro
yeah over there type pip
and then space install
and then space pandas
p-a-n yeah perfect and press enter
oh okay uh
type pip3 instead of pip install pandas
pip3
and then space install pandas
okay great
okay so now you have to do the same
thing
so pip three install numpy instead of
pandas
so do the same thing install numpy
yeah and enter
okay great now run the the code it
should work
so the the top green arrow that means
you're running the code
hurrah great so you're done with both
r and python so
um due to time
i didn't think it would take so long but
um i will help you guys
out dr mohith will help you out
in the next session on friday to whoever
needs more help with the programming
aspect and we will
yeah we'll help you on friday in after
the evening
like or after the session if you have
more issues with the programming aspect
but do come earlier if you also feel
like you need help
depending on how dr mohit depending on
if you can handle that or balance that
and uh yeah you can um you can also meet
me
i usually teach the monday session so
you can meet me after
near the end of the session to also talk
about your programming issues
all right so hopefully everyone learned
how to install both and if not we'll
we'll uh talk more about it uh in the
next session and the session after that
okay
all right i will see you guys next
session all right
no problem all right see you candice
i see you purity assemble oh and use
this slack channel
use this take screenshots and put it on
the slack channel
someone will definitely uh get to you on
the slack channel
okay i'll paste the link to the slack
channel just in case
you don't have it already
okay
one second i'll just
uh could you type your emails and i'll
send you a link
if you if you don't have a if you can
you type your emails so i can send you a
link
okay please send your emails and i'll
add you to the slack channel
oh okay candace you're already in but
whoever else
uh isn't in i'll add you to the slack
channel and then i'll see you guys
in a future session all right you can
you're free to leave dr
candice it was nice uh uh helping you
out okay [ __ ] there perfect
okay i will add you okay
sorry uh just because of time
constraints i'm gonna have to head out
right now
but i'll add you guys to the slack
channel uh
just if you aren't already there okay
yeah see uh
some of you guys are not here already so
i'm gonna add you guys
okay i added to symbol
i and i'm going to add a wallet
d milad uh purity
if you're there please give me your
email and i'll add you to the slack
channel
if not you can always ask next session
okay so hopefully you guys got the
invitation
and i will see you next session okay
all right all right see you guys
okay bye
bye
do you guys get the invite yes yeah okay
that's fine
okay bye